we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P I'm going to play this
is a really sad voicemail this is a
longer voicemail than I would normally
play
but the reason I'm playing it is I want
to show you how far reaching the uh
being victimized by disinformation can
be this is a caller who has been
completely victimized by disinformation
and he's fallen for a lot of really
wacky things let's listen
hey David I listened to your clips on
YouTube just to see what you're talking
about and uh okay vmla degree disagree
with basically everything you say when
it comes to vaccinations
um I really don't understand how
something that's not even really
properly SDA approved has known side
effects including gas mileage artists
carditis
including all kinds of Adverse Events
which is well documented
uh how can the left be so so aggressive
in their stance on vaccination and uh
like I said I'm just a concerned parent
concerned citizen something that I don't
really
uh plan on partaking in I will feel like
please announce you to deny it I think
it's uh it goes against everything that
this country is based upon fundamentally
that we allow corporations that
basically own this place to dictate what
is injected into our bodies in order to
to hold a job to create Commerce to
transact to travel
um and I never I've never been much of a
political person not really political
standing I'm just concerned about my
health and wellness and I really have a
big problem with corporations and people
that are in the political sphere
politicizing Health and Wellness
and I just I'm curious why why don't you
have somebody on your show who's
actually well informed on the science of
the time behind what's in these
injections I mean there's documented
proof coming out about all kinds of
parasites in the injections uh graphene
oxide all kinds of different things and
I'm sure you could have somebody on
who's very well versed in these things
and you can have a rational discourse
about what's actually going on instead
of uh shaming people for not partaking
in the science experiment all right
thank you so much
so as you can see this is someone who's
been victimized in many many ways and
they just believe all sorts of things
that aren't true now let's just talk I
mean like one two three four five six
seven so I was taking notes as he spoke
so he said that the vaccine is not
actually approved so there are three
vaccines approved by emergency use
authorization and the Pfizer vaccine is
fully approved so that's not true he
said that the vaccines are leading to
countless deaths
um we after our last segment I got a few
emails ended further research there are
three deaths that are being investigated
as to whether
vaccine caused myocarditis which led to
death it's being investigated it's being
investigated okay so compared to the
number of deaths from covet and of
course the relative risk from the
vaccine it's close to zero
um he said that corporations are
dictating what you must have injected uh
I'm not aware of that I'm aware of
Corporations saying if you want to make
the decision to work here here are our
requirements and different corporations
have required different vaccines for
decades that's not anything new
um he said he's just concerned about
health for his family and himself well
the best way to stay healthy when it
comes to covet is to get vaccinated he
said I could have a well-informed guest
on to talk about the science I have
we've had immunologists
um uh Isaac bogosh a doctor and we've
had arguably the top virologist in the
country Vincent rack and yellow those
are the experts he said that the vaccine
has parasites inside of it that's not
true and then just to pick one to talk a
little bit more about he said the
vaccines have graphene oxide in them
this came from so just to tell you where
that came from
a professor in Spain
claimed that there were tests done of a
vial of the vaccine and what was
supposedly a dose of the Pfizer vaccine
supposedly has graphene oxide in it now
it's been fact checked there's no
evidence that there's graphene oxide in
the vaccine a Pfizer has denied it it's
not listed on the list of ingredients
and it's not actually been demonstrated
that this guy even analyzed an actual
vial of the Pfizer vaccine that's where
it comes from and so in just a minute
this this goes to what Sam Harris
recently said about sometimes the
futility of debating these folks in a
minute and 49 second voicemail he was
able to start seven what Sam Harris
would refer to as small fires which now
we would be in a position to have to put
out each of them one by one and if you
fail to put out all seven convincingly
it may actually do damage further damage
so it's uh agree or disagree with Sam
Harris his assessment of the the sort of
difficulty of arguing with these people
very very well stated and this is just
one example we've got a great bonus show
for you today sign up on my website grab
a membership at joinpakman.com and then
we'll see you on the bonus show